hi I'm Erik Bosse and the Bender's
endgame dee-lighted us with the twist of
fat Thor also known as Lebowski Thor or
Thor most of us can finally cosplay as
shirtless Lee abs are great but you
can't balance a bowl of guacamole
up and up about how and why Thor takes
this turn and endgame but also the
mystery of why he stays this way
throughout the movie like seriously if
you're watching closely Thor stays and
his easy where for most of the movie
he's still wearing cracks at Tony
Stark's funeral why I don't know most of
us are thinking he'll why not but still
let us dig into this melted ice cream so
when it came to the decision to first
reveal four had gained this weight the
screenwriters said that they were
inspired by the Marvel what-if comics to
take each Avenger into a different
extreme after the five-year time jump
following Thor going for Thanos his head
for Hulk it was what if the Hulk was
smart for Hawkeye it was what if Hawkeye
was a murderous vigilante who actually
is in the movie this time and for Thor
it was what if the hunk who more than
any other Avenger branded Marvel as the
purveyor of gratuitous male
shirtlessness really let himself go with
a shaggy neckbeard in a gamer good this
reveal is fantastic and it's even
foreshadowed with a shot of Thor
starting his carbo heavy diet early in
the film with a beer in Hawaiian sweet
rolls Hemsworth said that this new
appearance required three hours of hair
and makeup with a silicone prosthetic
suit that weighed 90 pounds
he'd have weights on his hands and
ankles just to have his arms and legs
swing differently when he shuffled
around he said that people would come up
to him and cuddle him like a big bear
and rub his belly like he was pregnant
or sit on his lap like he was Santa
Claus and eventually he just got sick of
all the unwanted attention but here's
the really interesting thing about that
Thor an end game he stays bad Thor
Hemsworth revealed that originally Thor
was supposed to revert to his old buff
self in the middle of the film Hemsworth
said that he fought to keep his curves
sane I enjoyed that version of Thor it
was so different than any other way I
play the character and then it took on a
life of its own this exposes another
alternate deleted scene from the in-game
story one in which Thor after being
found flabbily by banner and rocket new
Asgard Norway gets back in shape so that
planning Monta
with the Avengers in HQ when Hulk was
eaten ice cream has been in Gerry's
flavor hunka hunka burning fudge the
others were eating sushi this alternate
scene would have showed four dieting
probably scowling at Hulk for being able
to eat whatever he wants and then maybe
piss anyone off by microwaving fish and
broccoli in the kitchen Thor's pathetic
moping over Jane Foster could have come
out between sets in the Avengers HQ gym
which we know was there because another
deleted scene showed Natasha working out
with a punching bag really nothing's a
better motivator to get in a few more
reps than an ex-girlfriend who's one of
the world's leading astrophysicists and
you're a disgrace of injury cutoff
Thanos's head way too late and now lives
with your bachelor buds from a trash
planet screaming threats of children who
pick on your roommate over fortnight
instead of all this the fact door we got
gives the characters so much more
comedic depth than the second and third
acts of the film like to see him
sneaking past Loki on ahead guard and
marching up to Thanos in the final
battle instead of the same old buff Thor
that we've always seen Thor gets some
wicked viking beard braids when he
charges up and really the best payoff
comes when Lebowski Thor banters with
Peter quill and the guardians of the
galaxy ship at the end of the film these
two jesting about who's the real captain
of these as guardians of the galaxy
reflects their rivalry at the beginning
of infinity war remember when the
Guardians teased quill about his weight
a muscular butt who you kidding well you
one sandwich away from that yeah right
it's true
what it's one of my favorite meta jokes
from these Avengers movies because aside
from Chris Hemsworth Chris Pratt is the
next Avenger whose figure has always
been weirdly obsessed over mostly
because he was previously better known
in his fat prat form as ad Dwyer on
Parks and Rec Marvel Studios caste
director Sarah thin the true visionary
behind this franchise revealed that
Pratt actually auditioned to be an
Avenger before reading for Captain
America Steve Rogers but of course that
role went to another blond Chris Chris
Evans
so Pratt has always had a chip on his
shoulder as the third in see you Chris
and now after hilariously comparing
their muscularity early an infinity war
Chris two slides and do Chris threes
former funnier flabbier shoes which are
and hopefully forever will be cracks do
you think Thor should stay fat Thor for
future Marvel films comment down below
with your thoughts and follow me on
instagram and twitter at da boss and of
course subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our Marvel breakdowns thanks for
joining me and yeah I can hear you in
the comments comparing me to fat or fat
Pratt you know it's okay if I do it but
when you say it it's mean so stop you do
not have to yes and self-deprecation
[Music]